tonight we're going to talk about the
words you use most often during the day
i think time
well this being new york and maybe the
second most used word you use during the
day
uh
but time cross is universal think about
all the times i'm saying it again when
you use the word time during the day i
don't have the time what time is it you
know do you have time for this and it's
a topic that crosses all disciplinary
you know issues like
theologians wonder about time and
scientists talk about time philosophers
talk about time and so tonight we're
going to encompass all these questions
that people have about time like
when did time begin
when when will time end
is time real
is an illusion because these are things
that scientists talk about and they
discuss
these things amongst themselves and
we're going to bring that to light today
talking about time and so everything you
wanted to know about time is is going to
be discussed this evening and we are
honored to have a fantastic panel of uh
scientists philosophers who will come up
here and talk about time let me
introduce them to you
first paul davies a theoretical
physicist and one of the world's leading
expert on time paul come on come on in
and have have a seat
he's professor arizona state university
and he's also the person that if we ever
get you know if we ever get a uh
et to phone in you you're assigned to
talk to that
extraterrestrial man yes you're the man
from ours he also has a
he also has an asteroid named after him
paul davies asteroid it's number 6870 in
your program if you're looking to look
up that it's not going to hit us with
that my one isn't going to hit us
also joining us is uh max tegmark max
he's a cosmologist who bridges
theoretical
and and experimental physics he's known
as as mad max is that that right man
that's right mad max he's a professor at
mit he works with the sds s
collaboration what does that stand for
the sloan digital sky survey
wow right out of star trek
then that's on galaxy clustering and he
shared the first prize in science
magazine's breakthrough of the year in
2003. welcome max
also joining us we are first of two
philosophers talked about philosophers
talking about time because when you get
into discussions about time it's almost
like talking about
philosophy tim maudlin welcome from nyu
he has authored many books that explore
the mysteries of physics quantum
non-locality and relativity there will
not be a test on this truth and paradox
the metaphysics within physics and the
philosophy of physics space and time
he's going to help us discuss it from a
philosophical point of view perhaps this
evening
also uh an aptly named guest craig
calendar he is professor
a philosophy at the university of
california san diego
he's author of the graphic text
introducing time as well as the editor
of the new oxford handbook of philosophy
it's a patronamic destiny if your name
is crook you become a crook if your name
is calendar philosopher of time there
you go is it a big is the oxford book a
big handbook small handbook yes it's
extremely large it's it'll it could
break something if you drop it it could
break a table
all right we won't put it down
let's let's begin with you paul let's
talk about uh you spend a lot of your
time thinking about time let's set the
stage let's turn back the clock a little
bit uh set the scene for us and explain
how einstein decided to get involved
with concepts of time right like so like
all of us einstein lay awake at night as
a teenager wrestling with the problem
you know what is time
my my favorite definition is time is
just one damn thing after another
but uh he he came to realize that there
was a conflict a deep conflict in
physics and we're talking about the turn
of the 20th century deep conflict in
physics uh between two things one of
which is very familiar so you must have
had the experience of sitting in a
railway carriage and you think oh we're
we're moving off and it's a train on the
parallel track going the other way
that's often called the principle of
relativity that uniform motion is
relative uh you're familiar with it as
well i don't know if you ever have this
experience a lot of people are afraid of
flying
i do a lot of flying some i'm not afraid
but the one thing that happens to me
almost inevitably as the plane taxes out
to take off i fall asleep
just happens almost every time
so then when i wake up
i have no idea whether we're airborne or
still on the runway and that's because
smooth flight you can't tell you can
drink your coffee and uh you know play
marbles or whatever same laws of physics
so that's been known since the time of
galileo that the laws and mechanics are
relative there's no
you can talk about
my speed relative to you but nobody's
got an absolute speed so that was
already known um but this was in
conflict with what had been discovered
in the 19th century
about
uh the way that light behaves so lights
are an electromagnetic wave and the
equations for electromagnetism were all
worked out in the 1850s by james clark
maxwell
and
from the mathematics of those equations
well i'm not going to go into that but
from the mathematics of those equations
it was clear that the speed of light is
supposed to be a fixed number a constant
well how can you reconcile the
relativity of motion with a constant
speed of light because what happens if
you chase after a light beam can you
overtake the light that's what he was
wondering you know if it's what if i
chase after that if it's coming at you
surely you'll encounter the light at a
higher speed than if you dashing away
from it and he realized these two
pillars of physics couldn't both be
correct and the only way to reconcile
them was to do something funny with time
and space as well as it happens we're
going to just talk about time
basically
in daily life we think that time and
space are just sort of there it's an
arena in which the great drama of nature
is acted out but what einstein said is
no that the these
space and time are part of the cast
they're part of nature just like mata
can be changed
manipulated so space and time can be
changed or manipulated it's often called
warping time or time dilation so he had
decided that your time and my time
might not be the same if we're moving
differently
and uh
well i can demonstrate it right away
that we can we can introduce a time
difference just by
me walking up now
that's all it takes now you might say
but that must be a trivial amount it's
true but if i took a a plane as i'm
going to one
on monday to london
and then come back again and we compare
your clock and my clock if they're good
clocks we see there's a difference
because we've been moving differently
and then just the movement changes just
the movement but because light is the
the key to this uh to get a really big
time warp you need to move it close to
the speed of light and in effect what
you are doing if you zoom off at close
to the speed of light is you are leaping
into the future quicker so it's a sort
of time travel into the future it means
you can get to a future event faster so
you fancy living to the year 3000 or
here on earth well you can either do it
the slow way and sit here for a thousand
years or you zoom off close to the speed
of light and get to the year 3000 in say
one year so what it means is that the
interval of time between two fixed
events can depend on the way you move so
time is not absolute it's relative as we
say he also realized that gravity does
funny things to time time
we're going to get into this later runs
and i don't think time runs at all but
i'll use the words for now time runs a
little bit faster up on the roof than it
does in the basement once again this is
a measurable effect we're going to talk
later on how you measure these effects
so in other words you know time is
something that depends on how you're
moving and what your situation is well
we hear about the symmetry of time what
is what does that mean
well it's another big puzzle in physics
been around for for a long time uh which
is that all of the laws of physics with
one minor exception
are symmetric under uh
interchanging past and future that is to
say that the laws themselves don't have
an inbuilt directionality
the time could run
forward or backwards give you a very
good example so you take a movie film of
the earth going around the sun
like that play backwards that's a
perfectly acceptable solution of a
physical situation but why don't we see
it then why don't we see things going by
us the other direction all the time
so to speak
well well the point i want to make is
that
simple systems
reflect this underlying symmetry of time
but when we get to complicated systems
then there seems to be a directionality
and we see this all the time
in everyday life so this would be a
scene familiar to everybody okay so what
we're seeing is uh
an ordered state of matter
uh spontaneously
turning into a disordered state now if
we see this running backwards
you see everybody laughs because
you you know it's preposterous
but according to the laws of physics
that could happen that could happen
and so the question is where does this a
symmetry of times arrow of time that is
so pervasive in daily life where does it
come from how does it originate
we do well i know the answer but
my colleagues may disagree uh but um uh
really ultimately you trace it back to
the origin of the universe the universe
began in an ordered state and it's
becoming progressively more disordered
we'll get into that a bit later a little
bit uh um
uh let me ask uh craig can you take us
from here what was you know einstein's
concept of time and
uh
what did he think about
you know
uh yeah so i think it was really a
fundamental reconception
reconceptualization of of the way we
think of time
so you know from newton onward you think
of time as having this you know unique
privilege present carving up the
universe
if you think of a ham or something and
you think of it going through a deli
slicer this one one way of slicing that
ham up
uh einstein on the other hand thought
well there really there really isn't any
such thing as time and space there's
space time just these events which are
inherently spatial temporal
and i can carve that up in different you
know just like i could throw the ham in
different ways and carve it up different
ways you could also carve up the
the events of the world into space and
time in different ways and that there's
no unique way of doing that
so it was crazy so we had to unite space
and time together to create a new
construct yeah and i think uh well to me
i don't know what the others think but i
i i you don't really see it so so
clearly in his original 1905 paper but
later in
1908 uh minkowski his teacher really
puts it in that framework
in fact also with a philosopher
mctaggart who raised all these sort of
puzzles for time in 1908 too so 1908 was
a bad year for time
max what do you think yeah i think
before einstein most people thought of
space as this three-dimensional place
where things happened over time
and then einstein
changed this viewpoint and really we
should think of reality as this
four-dimensional
space-time where time is just the fourth
dimension and nothing
is ever happening the past the present
the future is in there you know so if
our life is a movie then space-time is
the entire dvd
and you can travel within any of that
time forward backward if you slice it up
can you get to all the slices well
einstein would say that the
the space time is just static like a
beautiful crystal you can have in your
filing cabinet or something the dvd is
not changing right it's wrong to say
that the actor in the dvd who's the hero
is traveling through the dvd it's all
there and there are just these different
moments in the actor's life that are in
different places of of the space time to
now use right einstein's language so
it's a very different way of thinking
about reality yeah tim i see you have a
furrowed brow yeah about all of this
so
so i let me just actually because max
just said something that's often said
and i think it's misleading
he said space-time is static right we
know what something that static is it's
something that doesn't change with time
now
time is in space time sure stuff changes
stars collapse right you know life
evolves all of this is physical fact
it's things changing with time with the
temporal structure so of course even you
know a long time ago you could say
there's a
four-dimensional thing which includes
the entire history of the universe from
beginning to end but to say it's static
or things really aren't happening or so
on i i don't think that um that anything
really justify i wouldn't know what
sense to make out of such a such a story
about the world we live in right
do you think it's just too much maybe
it's too philosophical not based nothing
real science no i i think it's a as
we'll see i think it's a
misinterpretation of what uh what the
mathematics is telling us and and a
little bit of sloppiness about our
language this is awesome philosophers
always irritate us physicists by
catching us when we use language
sloppily so let me retract the word
static and see if i can say the same
thing
without using that word
we physicists love studying things
mathematically we study this
mathematical structure called
minkowski space which is a nerdy way of
saying space time
and we would say that space time does
not exist
in time or in space for that matter but
rather space and time exist within it it
didn't say static absolutely and that
you that you have to blend space and
time together i mean as we'll see you
can actually sort of get rid of space at
the end a funny thing you can do in
relativity is you can actually instead
of getting rid of time what you can do
is get rid of space when we may talk
about that a little bit
did i did the relativity and einstein
talk about whether
uh time changes i mean does it is it the
same all over the universe or is it same
everywhere is it intervals of time can
be different depending on where you are
and how you're moving as i was
explaining so when i say intervals of
time between two fixed events
and the classic example that everybody
likes to talk about is called the twins
effect it's sometimes called the twins
paradox it's not paradoxical
so supposing ara you and i were twins so
obviously born on the same day same age
i go off in a rocket ship
very close to the speed of light and i
go for uh
say two years
and when i get back i find you're 20
years older i've been moved so close to
the speed of light this time dilation
has done that so i have in effect leapt
18 years into your future
and people want to say well who is right
well we're both right my time and your
time are not the same you stayed at home
i went in the rocket ship we're both
correct the two end events my departure
and my return we agree on they're fixed
events but the interval of time between
them
depends on how you're moving and we can
measure this stuff no problem it's
measured every day
we're going to hear a bit more about it
but most obviously with the global
position i want to move into that but
tim is just jumping at the bit here let
me try again
something i think it is often said and
is misleading
go to your first point about relativity
you say if you go off near the speed of
light
how fast are we moving right now
we're moving
nine nine 99.99 the speed of light
that's a perfectly good frame we're not
moving any particular speed
now what about the twins well if you've
got two people and two cars and they
start in the same place and they drive a
while and their odometers start at zero
and they get back together and their
odometers have different mileages on
them
it's not really a paradox they went
different paths and their paths were
different lengths and what their
odometers was measuring those lengths
perfectly accurately no every odometer
went a mile per mile along their path
well that's all clocks do and in the
twins case let's the two twins follow
different paths and the paths are
different lengths and those links are
the times along that path and that's all
there is to it okay well let's talk
about that because in in science
measurement is everything right you you
come up with a theory einstein has a
theory people have theories but theories
are no good unless you can perform an
experiment and actually predict
something is going to happen and measure
whether that's going to happen let's
talk about predicting einstein was right
how do you prove craig how do you prove
time dilation and time dilation is the
idea that if you go close to the speed
of light or you're speeding up toward
the speed of light
time slows down right that be
oversimplifying
so there were a number of uh experiments
these classic experiments uh where
uh you know i think it was on the
concorde right uh the half dome
no it wasn't like before that was back
in the 50s so they didn't have concord
then didn't they put it didn't they put
a clock on a satellite well well they
did that too but they're thinking about
that
experiment flying around
the world in opposite directions
pre-concord i'm afraid so if you if you
put if you
work better if you believe that if you
get faster if you move faster and faster
close to the speed of light and time
slows down a bit you can perform an
experiment where you have a clock that's
standing still and a clock that's moving
really fast and see if they keep the
same time and that has been done that's
right that was what was done was you
know synchronize the the ones on the
planes to the one on the earth send the
planes off in different directions come
back and then not synchronized anymore
the clocks don't measure the same time
anymore no
that's just for moving just from going
to a faster velocity and the global
positioning system is doing this all the
time so this is an everyday experience
if you took the time dilation out of the
algorithm taxi drivers will be lost
within hours actually we should see how
many experiment lists we have raise your
hand if you have a cell phone on you
with gps
you found your way here so your gps is
working all right so this this proves
relatively right yeah so they use atomic
clocks to prove these things you need a
really accurate clock right better than
the traditional atomic clock but but
this is the way that it was done back in
the 50s and 60s uh using an atomic clock
what is an atomic clock well atoms are
very good clocks they emit
light or radio waves uh electromagnetic
waves anyway at very precise frequencies
uh and if you've got a frequency it's
like a beat
like a metronome and so uh the emission
of uh of light or radio waves by an atom
gives you a time standard and you can
create a clock that locks onto that
frequency and that can be very very
accurate
these days we can go beyond that
technology and we were talking earlier
is it like to 13 significant figures
17 significant figures
you can measure time so accurately now
we even define the speed of light in
terms of the second
so this clock is so accurate and it
could measure
just if you lift it off the ground put a
foot the most accurate one because
when the gravitational field changes the
geometry of space time and so if i lift
something just a foot off the ground a
[ __ ] up here is traveling through a
different patch of space time than a
[ __ ] down here and has a slightly
different geometry because of gravity
and you can you can actually measure the
difference
uh wow
the difference in the gravitational
field uh at that level with the accuracy
of the clocks
when you're standing or upright the
clock in your head is going
ticking differently than the one
here of whether you i were older or you
also solves over
paul are older in the twin parallel docs
because he went off you went off so you
accelerated and he didn't that's right
said that acceleration and gravity are
kind of cool
didn't he look at me and think i was
accelerated no no no you must imagine
yeah i mean if you
if if i'm accelerating away and you're
on the earth and i look at you it looks
like you're exhausted right now
you're the uniform the period of uniform
motion of course you're right there's a
symmetry
measure
lengths
so you imagine your your clock is going
through space time it's following a path
through space time what a clock measures
is how long it is and acceleration is
how bent the path is so if you're going
through space-time and you suddenly
change direction you accelerate right
clocks measure lengths not being bent
it the acceleration has nothing to do
with the effect the only thing that has
and you know this is true do with
gravitational lensing the effect just
has to do with different path lengths
through space-time yeah i disagree with
that key point we want to get clear
clear up here though is that ira is
right you cannot tell the difference
between sitting still and moving
uniformly now earth is whizzing around
the sun right now at 30 kilometers per
second
can you feel it no but if you're in a
car and you step on the accelerator real
hard you feel pushed back
you can feel if you're accelerated what
einstein pointed out is you can't tell
whether you're actually accelerated or
just in really strong gravity
um but either way you can tell it's you
were being squished against the back of
your rocket seat ira wasn't yeah that's
that's
how that breaks this is a lot of people
think oh there's a paradox because in
your reference frame i should be aging
more
i think you should be aging more but
there's no paradox i'm not accelerating
that's that no you don't buy that but
they agree
you could do this with two unaccelerated
clocks gravitational lensing right you
both agree
send two clocks different ways around a
star gravitationally nobody accelerates
yes and they pick off different lengths
different different amounts it depends
on their exactly that could happen if it
was
let's talk about how because we're
trying to talk about how do you measure
this how can you measure the effects and
show that you know test out einstein's
theories we're talking about here on
earth with clocks and with uh with
special uh
special clocks what about looking out
into the cosmos can we look out there
and see if there are experiments
happening on their own that could
measure these max yeah so we heard from
paul
you guys here that
both speed and gravity can mess with the
rate at which time flows and
what i love about being an
astrophysicist is that when we look at
the space these aren't just tiny effects
that you have to measure 17 decimal
places to notice they're huge effects
they're really in your face
to me as an astrophysicist the idea that
gravity slows down time is just as
obvious as it is to you that stepping on
the brakes slows down your car it's a
big effect and the most
spectacular thing we can do nearby is
just go to the monster black hole it
lives in the middle of our milky way
galaxy that's not a real black hole
isn't it this is a really awesome
simulation of it that my friend andrew
hamilton
made but the black hole i have bad news
is real it weighs four million times as
much as the sun does this intimidating
looking circular disc that you see is
the event horizon the region where the
gravity is so strong that nothing not
even light can escape from it that's why
it's black right and the weird patterns
you see around it
are simply this powerful gravity bending
the light raids like we heard here
just like a funny mirror in the
amusement park would mean the light
raids and
make your face look funny and we can
actually go there without using hardly
any rocket fuel at all if we
go in an orbit that gradually spirals
into it
and parks in what i like to call the
tourist orbit which is exactly twice the
radius of a short shoulder radius it's
an unstable orbit so
don't fall asleep at the steering wheel
because if you make a mistake you know
it might be your last yes but while
we're orbiting around there our friends
on earth will see us orbit around the
long distance there about the same
distances from the sun to the earth in
16 minutes
and how long does it take the sunlight
to get from the sun to earth it takes
nine minutes yeah about eight minutes so
that means people on earth see us going
at half the speed of light
without using much fuel that's cool fuel
efficient time travel and it's green and
yet when we are in there it will we will
measure that it takes 16 minutes to go
around so our time has slowed down to
half the rate which means if i'm skyping
back home to earth to my mommy
i'll be going like
oh
mommy
and she will see not just that my brain
is running slowly down there but she
will also see that the clock on board
our spaceship and everything else is
also running at half the speed so she
will actually correctly infer
that i will not be able to tell from
looking at paul davis and my other
fellow travelers in the spaceship that
anything is weird it'll seem totally
normal to us because we're all slow down
together and instead
when i look at mommy on earth i will see
her speaking twice as fast so she'll be
going like oh max i'm so worried about
you i think just i'm so nervous that
you're speaking so slowly and i'm
worried but you're gonna suck in this
black hole
and i'll be like i'm fine mommy
you know
this is the key principle of relativity
that we just heard about which is that
you always think you are right about the
flow of time and that everybody else is
wrong it's just like if you feel that
you're having an argument with someone
and you know you're right and they're
wrong and then it suddenly hits you that
that's exactly how they feel too right
right like
are supernova explosions a good source
of looking for experiments with time
that's another really really cool uh
in your face example we've told you a
tall tale here about all this cool stuff
sounds good right but why should you
believe a word of us of this what's the
evidence
well we've actually seen clocks
run slowed down by black holes because
we heard from paul that we can think of
even atoms as clocks where instead of
the pendulum on grandpa's
clock it's the frequency with which
things are vibrating and it's the clock
and this is a really cool simulation
that my colleague ben bromley made of
how the iron atoms
slow down near a black hole and when
they slow down they emit light at a
slower frequency which looks red as you
can see here
and the best measurements we have of
spectra of these so called iron k alpha
lines confirm this and show direct
evidence that the atoms near black
holes are
have their time going at only half the
speed it's crazy it's crazy very in your
face and if you have the next slide
there with the supernova that ira asked
about
black holes
are gravity on steroids right now we
have speed on steroids because
here we have galaxy moving away from us
near the speed of light and we see a
supernova go off boom you can see a
flash going off there
for a brief moment the supernova
outshines all the other stars in the
galaxy we see it rise and we see it fade
in a very interesting regular way which
was recently used to win the nobel prize
in physics
and the cool thing is that when you look
at supernovae they're really far away
traveling away near the speed of light
you see them blowing up not poof but
they blow up in slow motion
you can really see
the time has slowed down down it's not
like david wineland's atomic clock where
you need to measure 17 decimal places to
see the effect
it's in the first decimal place you know
the it's a factor of two tim you're
buying all of this
i mean again it's it
there's a geometry everything i i the
talk about their clock slow down uh i
think can be misleading just in my
analogy about the odometers nobody's
odometer was broken right if if the two
cars went different paths and they they
showed different lengths all the clocks
are doing what they should do right
which is measuring the the local
geometry of space time where they are
that's what i was going to say so then
by looking at time being different in
the black hole and to where time is here
so time is a local event
the how time passes the time is a local
event it changes yes
structure is local in space time it's
really things that are that are going on
you can think of the total time
structures a matter of what's going on
in each little region locally added up
if you as you pass from region to region
sure
so does that mean we can
by going faster we you're saying we can
actually go ahead
in time relative to something else yeah
always relative
so that's what science fiction movies
talk about maybe going and going yeah
time traveling for the future
we've done that that's right you get to
the future quicker you get to the going
to the past is a whole different subject
we're not going to get into
we we decided we would quarantine that
right
you use the analogy to space again if
i'm flying in an airplane why do
airplanes fly over the north pole
because it's shorter if i went
just staying at the same uh uh
latitude
right it would be longer right
paths between the same two points some
are shorter some are longer if if
they're shorter and this is in space
time it means your clock will tick off
less time you'll age less you know so if
you're only going to live 40 years you
can get to a different spot than you
could if you if you win it a very
different way
all right let's let's move on about time
because there's so much time to talk
about it um
let's talk about when
time
began
and will time end
i mean are these phyllis more than
philosophical questions
okay so paul give us give us an idea
when was it the big bang the time began
coming back to einstein so once he'd
established the idea which now everybody
accepts that space-time are physical
things they're not just there not just
an arena but they're part of the physics
they can change
one of the things that was soon
discovered is that time can become so
distorted and space as well
that
it in effect becomes infinitely
distorted and then at that point you
would say time stops when it's
infinitely distorted right right because
supposing you know we've been talking
about how clocks can
get out of kills with each other if you
like run at different speeds if that
became an infinite effect you'd think
well what what is going to happen and
the big bang
this is popularly called the origin of
the universe could be one such point in
our past where there is uh what we call
a singularity in spacetime uh infinite
curvature infinite distortion
uh and
under those circumstances the big bang
would be the origin of time now when i
was a student everybody accepted that
they thought there was a big bang
time began with the big bang and dinner
parties people always want to ask well
what happened before the big bang and
what caused the big bang and you
scientists think you're so clever but
you can't explain that can you ha you
see
and i i think um stephen hawking is
impressive very well
he said that
asking what
lies before the big bang is like asking
what lies north of the north pole you
can ask the question it sounds like a
sensible question the answer is nothing
lies north or the north pole not because
there's some mysterious land of
nothingness there because there ain't no
such place as north of the north pole in
relativity there ain't no such time as
before the big bang
in a simple picture the picture that
everyone believed in when i was a
student these days we can't be sure that
what we call the big bang was the
ultimate origin of time it could have
just been a little local bang in a
bigger system
uh which max is going to talk about
tomorrow and you're the multiverse which
uh itself might be eternal but uh each
universe each bang within that bigger
system would have a beginning but it
wouldn't be the ultimate beginning so a
lot of universes with a lot of big bangs
right but no ultima no all-time
beginning so you so at this stage you
can have either you know if you believe
the simple picture the big bang was the
ultimate origin of time there was no
before
nothing caused it because it was the
origin of space-time and matter and same
thing with the end of time time can end
if
we looking at black holes if you fall
into a black hole there may be
singularity at the center of the black
hole we don't know that uh if there is
that could be the end of time but could
it also be the beginning of time well if
it's like a big bang isn't it like a
mini big bang that's another theory you
see so either time ends or it doesn't
end you know if it doesn't end then
something else isn't science
they just raise the questions they don't
answer them i mean isn't it like we were
talking about this being like philosophy
right philosophical could i add the
point about this make it even more
confusing
uh if you think of the singularity that
paul talked about as you know that it's
ill-defined
because the curvature goes
uh infinite and you model this like a
like the real number line say between
zero and one and so you think of the
real numbers all the decimal expansions
and so
now you take that point zero think of
that as the big bang
it's ill-defined so pluck it
so remove that zero point
well if you do that
you know what is the next number
uh
well is it
zero point zero zero zero zero zero zero
you know one no it's zero zero point you
know zero point zero zero et cetera no
there is no first moment
uh there is a first second though
so there is no first second uh first
moment of time but there is a
perspective
continuous
yes yeah and another way of
restating what what paul just said here
about north of the north pole if we come
back to this metaphor of thinking of the
cosmic movie sitting in this cosmic dvd
which ira conveniently has
then
if we ask what happened before the
beginning of the movie on this dvd
oh sorry this is a dvd
that's
what there is
at the same time
with all my work on actual data and
experiment i think to be honest and put
it in very technical terms uh i think we
have no clue
what really happened early on we have a
very good clue of what happened after
that during the next 13.8 million years
that we'll talk about but it's
fascinating as we just heard here how
it's gone from being that well in the
beginning there was the singularity of
general relativity two being a field now
with really active research
and loads of different competing ideas
that people actually argue about not
just in bars but actually at physics
conferences but i i think that's also
because at a certain time people were
learning general relativity if you take
those laws as sacrosanct and exact then
you can actually prove that there's a
singularity i mean it's it's a
mathematical theorem but of course
everybody knew these aren't the final
equations right there are going to be
they're going to have to be corrections
to them
to the to the well to certainly the
general relativity
general relativity only covered gravity
and only covered it probably at a large
scale
now they're well-defined equations and
you can study them with mathematical
precision but they're not the right
final equations of physics and of course
we only really know if there was
anything before the big bang and what it
was like if we get to a final theory and
we can analyze it a lot of work for you
guys that's their
you know talking about the big bang is
what happened before the big bang
reminds me the question we get asked
often on science friday and other
physicists from einstein down said well
if the universe is expanding
what's it expanding into right
yeah well we heard from well it's like
it's the reverse part of that question
of what came before the big bang we had
you with a guy on science friday who
explained it very well
we heard already
from paul here that einstein said space
isn't just this boring statics 3d thing
it's something which can be stretched
out so we tend to think of space kind of
like
what we learn in the news about the
middle east you can only get more space
by taking it away from someone else so
you can only expand out if you like say
move over it dude whereas actually
einstein said that space can stretch out
so our universe is right now creating
more cubic meters
or gallons of volume you know without
even without it taking
away from expanding
yeah not this room i can woody allen
let's point it out but but between the
galaxies far apart there is just our new
gallons being created
all over the place and uh they're not
being taken away from anyone else
well let's talk about the size of the
universe because i know that's what you
measure how big how big are we expanding
to what what are we up to yeah so this
is fascinating because
when i was
i'm still not that old right and and yet
when i started grad school i started my
career at cosmos we were arguing about
whether our universe was 10 billion
years old or 20 billion years old now we
argue about whether it's 13.7 or 13.8
billion so so what happened very briefly
what happened was data and like stuff
you mentioned in the intro and if you
imagine from yeah data numbers hard
measurements because if we imagine for a
moment that
i'm looking at our universe and each one
of you in the audience is a galaxy
then the first thing that would strike
me is that
you guys are all blushing
you here in the front row just blushing
a little but some of you guys in the
back are like tomato red in the face so
what what's going on all the galaxies
are actually looking redder than they
should well we know that if galaxies are
emitting red light
light with lower frequencies than it
should have that means its atoms are
vibrating too slowly so time is slowed
down in these galaxies and we just
learned that if the time is slowed down
in these galaxies it could be because
they're moving really fast away from us
and in fact
that's exactly what we mean when we say
our universe is expanding okay so as a
cosmologist i love
the weird stuff that happens to the flow
of time not just because it's cool
but because it's really useful and helps
us measure these sort of things and
we've measured very accurately now
that's one of the things we did with the
sloan digital sky survey we tried to
make the biggest 3d map of our universe
so far we measured very accurately how
fast different galaxies were going away
and
we found the more distant ones go away
faster
and
this is exactly the same principle as a
cop would use if he stops a car for
speeding saying hey my radar
that bounced back from your car was
going at too lower frequency
so
you must have been driving 100 miles an
hour you're busted right and if this cop
now notices that in your car right that
you have
all these diamonds which you've
obviously robbed from a jewelry store he
could figure out roughly when the crime
happened by just taking the distance to
the jewelry store and dividing by your
speed right and we can do exactly the
same game with these galaxies we take
the distance to a galaxy
divide by the speed
and ask how long ago was it here
and when we correct for acceleration we
get about 13.8
billion years now so we have
the time of the crime and
and moreover
by using these weird time effects again
just to measure stuff they come back to
irs question of how we really know it's
13.8
the next thing i would notice if i look
at you in the audience again and it's
not just that you're blushing but
there's another weird thing going on i
see
that you look younger and younger the
farther away i look you know i see a lot
of canes and walkers
yeah and there's a lot of spitballs in
the middle of the room and i see a bunch
of kindergartners there and toddlers and
some babies
and then it looks like
just the same way as you can see in the
universe slide i made up here where the
nearby galaxies are old and mature and
big far away galaxies small baby
galaxies why
because it takes time for the light to
reach us so looking far away is like
looking into our past and if you look
real close over there it looks like the
organizers kind of blew it with the
ticket sales because the last 10 rows
are empty there's no one in there
just kidding but that's what the
universe looks like right we see there
are no galaxies beyond a certain
distance we look so far away
they hadn't had time to form all you
have
is this transparent hydrogen gas out of
which the galaxies were formed later and
if we have the next slide that means
that when you look still farther away
you see something else really funky so
if i look out into the room i notice the
back wall there
it's glowing with a strange incandescent
radiation that's exactly what we see in
our universe because
when space expands the gas cools off
that's how your air conditioners
hopefully work
today right
and so in our early universe this gas
was hotter and hotter and hotter and and
sufficiently far back it's so hot that
it's a hydrogen plasma which is opaque
so it's
just like the wall you cannot see
through it it looks to us
as if beyond all these galaxies is a
wall of glowing hydrogen plasma and next
slide please we of course see that in
whatever direction we look so the way it
appears to us humans is as though we're
actually surrounded by a giant plasma
screen
this is the so-called microwave
background radiation
and uh this was on the front page of the
new york times just the other month the
planck satellite image and put it in
here
the way that it's not the earth that's
the that's the universe that's our
universe we're in the middle of this and
what you're looking at this ball is the
spherical region from which light has a
time to get here so far on the outside
of that thing no no if we wait this
another billion years light from there
can reach us and we can find out a bit
more but why is it why does it have
different colors in it what are the
different colors meaning ah it's a good
question because these baby pictures of
our universe are showing us
what this plasma looked like when our
universe was just four and a thousand
years old
and if it looked exactly the same color
everywhere if space were completely
uniform boring it would have to stay
that way and you would never make any
planets or stars and this meeting would
be cancelled
fortunately for us there was a little
bit higher density in some places than
others so you see some hot spots and
some cold spots in that map and over the
years
and
and billions of years gravity amplified
these tiny
clumps to big clumps like galaxies stars
people
and the world science festival
so to summarize i i think what we've
really learned
is that this business of time mon
acting funny isn't just the cool thing
it's extremely useful because every
single fact i told you ultimately is
something we've learned as scientists
from using that effect you know to our
advantage how far back you said you got
back to how far back was that to the 400
thousand so we can see yeah 13.8 billion
years ago
400 thousand years after
the thing that we have no clue about
how far back do you theoretically think
can you push it even further out to see
yes
we can as far as you like i mean the
main problem is we can't see through
that plasma screen right but if you go
to the doctor
and he says you know sorry i can't see
if your rib is broken because you're not
transparent ira you're going to be like
come on give me an x-ray already right
and sure enough there are other kinds of
radiation that can penetrate that
and for example neutrinos and even
gravitational waves ripples in the very
fabric of space-time
and uh
the next sensational big thing in
cosmology will be if we detect these
gravitational waves from from
10 to the power minus 34 seconds after
our big bang if this will happen if
the inflation theory is the correct
answer for what happened early on right
and if it happened in the simplest
possible way and and if it happens it'll
definitely be all over the science
friday you know in in the year
yeah white white on rice
but right now the frontier of our
ignorance i'd say goes at about one
second we can't see it but there's sort
of fossils left over from there just
like we know the dinosaurs were here
even though we can't see them we see
we know that if it was super hot you
know one second after a big bang
the hydrogen there should have done
exactly the same stuff that super hot
hydrogen does in the middle of the sun
fusion and we see the products of it
and
it all matches it's just pointing out
that the large hadron collider
recreates conditions that would have
prevailed about a trillionth of a second
after the beginning so we can sort of
make little patches of big bang
in the lab okay let's let's move on to a
question that i've been
dying to talk about about time and i've
been reading and talking with people
about and that is
is time and illusion is it we talk about
time you experience it but to some
scientist there's a great rift between
the folks who believe time is real and
time is an illusion how can time
paul tell us about time how is it time
real or why do some people say it's an
illusion well let's get into this right
you've got to be really careful to
distinguish
the when we talk about an interval of
time
or the passage of time so i don't
remember your life
no no i don't know many people who would
say
uh that we're uh doubting the fact that
uh the this session here is gonna last
one and a half hours and we can measure
that and that is a meaningful statement
so that that is one thing
but where uh
when people talk about time being an
illusion what they really mean is the
passage or the flow of time now we've
been very sloppy with our terminology
even max was talking about the flow of
time being faster you were talking about
time passes and i said don't say that
right don't use that word the p word um
uh uh herman valve expressive very well
time does not pass it merely is and so
we're back to this whole issue about
the dvd about
block time as is the technical term we
have space time it's just there i like
to call it the timescape we have the
landscape you can unfurl a map that
represents the land landscape in the
same way we've got the timescape
everything is there you have all events
for all of space time simply there
uh i i don't think anybody claims that's
an illusion so measuring an interval
with clocks between two events
is real okay but the question is what
about this impression that we all have
in daily life the time is flowing or
moving uh and you have you have a video
on it
and we do and i think i think it's an
illusion but i'd like to be betrayed
otherwise and this is my my favorite
analogy
and so
now everyone has had the same experience
you spin around like that and stop you
have this overwhelming impression that
the universe is rotating
okay you you feel it's uh this dizziness
everything's going around when you stop
but you can look at a spot on the wall
and you can see of course he's not
rotating you can your observation show
can't be rotating it feels in your head
like it is rotating
in the same way i'll demonstrate this
the same way you can't get away from
this idea it seems to be whizzing along
yeah
but when you stop to think about it well
it doesn't really mean anything to say
time is moving because movement is the
change of something position of a point
with time
but how what does it mean to say that
time is changing with time it means
nothing at all you say time changes at
one second per second but that's just a
tautology you know what else could it be
two seconds per second
and so
uh to a physicist uh and in fact this
was the famous quote of einstein to uh
to a committed physicist past present
and future only illusions however
persistent and this whole idea of a
universal now
uh and a march of time
i think craig's going to show us a video
uh shortly about this
it doesn't doesn't mean anything at all
so there's a huge conflict between our
daily experience that time is passing
and
the physicist view of time that has no
place within those any of those
equations there's no there's no device
that can measure the flow of time
there's a device that measures time
intervals it's called a clock no device
that can measure the flow of time no
time monitor so to speak great um and so
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo i
agree with paul uh and what i've been
working on a lot lately is uh
yes so this illusion of uh time flowing
uh well a i think it's really important
to us it's the way you know it's really
the time of our lives if we look at the
first
uh animation i have
yeah so i think we normally think as we
navigate through life
we normally think that there's you know
time and space
and we think that there's this you know
this moment this moment right here that
i'm talking to you right now you coming
to this event is what's happening this
is the present it's moving through
sweeping through the through world
history
uh
you know that there's this but it's you
know leaving behind this fixed and
settled past
and in front of you you know so my birth
is there uh socrates is death
uh in front though there's you know this
uh open uh you know ripe with
possibility uh future you know so right
now you could you know you know change
your actions in some way and become a
philosopher or a plumber or whatever
it's not there yet you think and as you
navigate through life you you think that
you have this uh it's all fixed you know
this past that whereas the future is all
open
and it makes a real difference to you
your attitudes about the past and the
future will differ in all sorts of
different ways
um and so it's really important to us
i think it's wrong you know so physics
tells us i think that it's wrong so
there you know relativity tells you that
that present there is no unique one
and so you could carve it all up
different ways
and so then that means hence the uh you
know what's what's fixed and what's open
you know there's no fact of the matter
about that either
you know is the uh what what events are
are uh
really open to us and that are are is
just not fixed
and so notice three things about this
picture one you've got the present being
really special you know that's what's
happening right now
uh two it divides up the past and future
and you attribute different properties
to this past and future so you think
one's fixed one is open
and then three it updates you know so
this whole tripartite structure is
updating itself with each moment
it's all complete rubbish
uh
but uh why you know why you know so if
you go anywhere any culture any you know
all people believe this uh you could
even do in some sense tests on animals
and they'll they in some sense have to
operate with a kind of model like this
why
and so i've been trying to figure out
how you know give a story about why why
creatures why uh why creatures like us
um you know come up with this kind of
conception of time even though it's
wrong
and so
uh if we so first i think it's really an
interdisciplinary thing because it
really requires some philosophy
physics psychology a whole bunch of
different features
that go into explaining why it is we
come up with this
so the first thing i want to explain is
why we feel like we're trapped in this
present moment and why we're stuck in
time if you like
if we
for that you need some physics and you
need some some psychology so the the
physics first if we run the next
animation
so here i'm going to talk about
imagine slicing the world up it's a
little weird to think about but imagine
slicing the world up
the normal way where you have all these
spatial moments one after the other
after the other
versus slicing it up
grabbing this 4d block that max talked
about his dvd
you know portions of the dvd imagine so
this is the normal slicing those are
little slices that are cut that's right
so those are different moments of time
going up in time
but you could also imagine grabbing you
know some other
plane of space and time and moving out
say to the east direction or you know
slicing you know in terms of the
different avenues in new york over time
and moving across new york across
manhattan that way
but if you did that
you would have a very unwieldy physics
you won't get as much information
uh
it's it's it's really important that we
slice up that we carve up the world the
way we did do
if you look at the you know in that in
that animation
the that ball you know if in the second
animation it becomes two balls
or if you like it has a or one ball
going back in time uh
but that's not what the way we think
about things and so we've got this time
being you know one dimensional there's
no backwards time travel
and so
so that's the physics part
the psychology part
uh
well think about the fact that you know
so when you're listening to me right now
hopefully i don't seem like a poorly
dubbed uh godzilla movie you know so my
my lips the image the visual impression
of my lips hopefully matches my
the sounds you're hearing
although
you know it's bouncing off my you know
the light is coming in bouncing off my
face at 300 000 kilometers per uh
meters per second the sound is coming in
you know woefully slowly at you know 300
meters per second and yet you know your
brain is putting the two things together
and you're doing this all the time
and it's happening so quickly
uh so we can see how you know we can see
where there's certain thresholds at
which we do it and it's very interesting
to see why we do it and when we do it if
we look at
so here we will see uh see a test here
so see how many people can tell which
which of these two dots happened the fir
first
anyone could could anyone tell
all right
uh yeah so that's like right at the
envelope of of uh it's 40 milliseconds
so it's right at the envelope of when
people can tell the difference uh the
next one people should be able to tell
the difference
and now the next one this one should be
really easy
and so you know we don't really notice
this but all the time our brains are
doing this you know so when it's uh
thunder and lightning it's the same
event
sound and light but our brains say no no
no we don't you know we don't bind those
two two things together but other things
we do think of as some you know uh c is
subjectively simultaneous
uh and there are all sorts of
interesting experiments too so you have
to think about uh ventriloquism you know
when you have a puppet
and what the puppet is doing is in space
attracting the sound right so the puppet
the the ventriloquist is you know by
making the mouth move is attracting the
sound over to that bit of of space
but you also have uh
time versions of this so you have a
temporal ventriloquism where you can
have uh you know flashes
attract the sound or sorry the other way
you can have uh the sounds attract the
flashes no wait the the first one was
right sorry uh you have the uh yeah so
the
if the other one just is regular
ventriloquism uh yeah um and so you have
all these sorts of you don't even notice
what's going on but your brain is doing
all these sorts of tricks it's getting
bombarded with all the you know think of
you know if you think of an explosion
you'd have uh you know heat waves those
pressure waves
light
sound all sorts of things coming in at
different signal speeds and yet you'll
you know put it all together and more or
less for microscopic salient events
you'll get it all
match the objective order
and sequence
all right so that's the psychology
there's a lot more to say about that but
put the physics together with a
psychology
why do we think that the now that that
present is really special and objective
well it's because
there's going to be a massive
intersubjective agreement about that
so i can just uh i reckon uh you know
say uh if one of these you know lights
or if the curtain was about to fall on
me he could say look out it doesn't need
to say look out now
or you could say look out now but it
doesn't need we need to say you know
you know uh craig synchronized watches
it's you know whatever gmt ready look
out
uh we can just because the time he says
it that lag time between the time i
process it and the time he also then
processes it is so fast that there's
going to be this interest objective
agreement about it and we can just use
this shorthand you know now or we don't
we could even drop the word now
on the other hand when if you think of
in space
yeah i don't think of the here is
special
why because you know we can walk around
in three dimensions in space we can do
you know because we can't time travel
uh but we can space travel so if you
think about it we can sort of bend
backwards in space so i could just walk
right back and forth and
in all these different spatial
directions but i can't do it in the in
time and so uh there's going to be this
massive interest objective agreement
about uh the now and we're not going to
find the spatial counterpart of that
uh so if you bear with me just quickly
i'll mention is okay two or two other
things quickly really quickly okay we're
running out of time
the other thing is
uh so why is the why is the uh
why is the past team uh fixed and the
future open
that's a puzzle uh
you know we have this causal asymmetry
we know about if i you know wiggle
something it'll have uh downstream
effects into the future but not the past
but that's true of all of all times um
why do we think that the uh the past uh
is is uh fixed in this way
and i think it has to do with the fact
that you know whether we have it really
or not we have
you know our subjective impression is
that we have this sense of free will
and so there are all these you know
self-fulfilling predictions i can make
about certain ranges of of
of
of actions
and that leads me to think that i have
that these these
the future is always open and i don't
have that about the past
think about you know
the the waiter is coming you've decided
what you're going to have for for dinner
and you're thinking i'm going to have
the chicken i'm going to have the
chicken i'm going to have the chicken
the waiter and maybe maybe uh everybody
here says you know he always gets the
chicken he's going to get the chicken
you know but i can you know i can always
uh you know ruin your prediction you
know right at that last moment you know
go for this sound fish yes go for the
fish and then
and i made it so and it seems to me that
i made it so and it's gonna seem really
open to me
okay so that's the fix business
uh why does it seem like i'm moving up
through time
in this way you know so it seems like
i'm getting closer to my death
but if this einsteinian picture is right
it's it's already there the past is
already there uh what's moving there's
nothing moving
well the way i think about it is this
you know you've got all these memories
and you've got these and they're nested
so you've got memories but not only
memories but memories of memories and
memories of memories of memories and
with these
uh this asymmetric stock of resources
you you devise this story
of a self
so i'm telling the the world this the
story of myself the story of craig
and
it's a fiction but the fiction is moving
up up the line
and so this is what gives me this idea
that i have this uh so that i get think
of the ego as moving and once you have
the ego moving then i think you've got
time moving there's a nice little
experiment uh that's done where people
say
you know get you to shift between these
two perspectives and ego moving and time
moving perspective so if i ask you
i say
next wednesday's meeting has been moved
forward two days
now which day is it on is it on monday
or is on friday
so people will switch back and forth uh
so some people say friday some people
will say monday it shows you can switch
back and forth between the sort of ego
moving and time moving perspective
and so then i think these are the three
components for explaining this why we
have this illusion that paul talked
about well tim i know you're chomping at
the bit here because you don't i'm the
only faint person up on the stage
apparently
you don't think this is a time is an
illusion at all no i i sometimes i
sometimes say it's i'm a wonderful
professional where i can actually put
food on the table going out giving
papers to defend the thesis that time
passes time passes
not for these guys uh yes
time you believe time is flowing i
believe time passes i believe it passes
in in a definite direction i believe i
can now decide what to have for dinner
and it can depend on what i do now and i
can't now decide what to have had for
breakfast this morning right um that's
that is beyond
the future the future is differently
oriented to the present than the past is
um and that there is an intrinsic
directionality to time and we are all
getting older unfortunately and closer
to the grave at the end of this show
than we were at the beginning um
i think these are trivialities i think
they're also true and i think physics
doesn't say anything that suggests
they're not true
there's no directionality to time
there's a directionality to the world in
time no i think that's the time
itself is a directive
geometrical object how do you measure
this directionality i can certainly
measure easily enough in million times
in a laboratory do you do measurements
about what happened first then next then
next yeah that's just earlier later
earlier later is an asymmetric relation
it's not the same as you know earlier
and later as an asymmetric relation it's
it's not if you just have a periodic
process it's really symmetric the world
is not
no that's the same periodic process
that's not nothing to retire and it's
got to do with the initial conditions of
the universe earlier and later is still
asymmetric even a periodic process you
just keep coming back again and again
and again over and over but you're
talking about states of the world you're
not talking about time i think this uh
passionate disagreement about the words
actually hides
a bit of an underlying agreement that
you have i think it's more the choice of
the words really than than the sentences
there's an interesting question how we
perceive time it's a complicated the
same way with space right you see the
the muller liar arrow things where the
one arrow looks longer than the other
and you measure it and they say they're
really the same so that's a kind of
visual illusion you don't say space is
an illusion okay so we there is
complicated neural processing about how
we come up with our perception of time i
don't think that has much to do with
physics it's an interesting separate
question not not to do with the physics
of time which is much more basic well
let me move on but i know well now we
know where you stand on this but you and
you have come up let's move right to
your uh a radical idea you've invented a
new math yes i have a new math
absolutely see if you can explain it all
right here we go this is going to be
fast
and serious and incomprehensible um
so
we've been talking about space time and
and and
uh
we've been talking about time as part of
the geometry of space time so what do we
mean by geometry what kind of structures
do we have in geometry well we just saw
on you could in geometry you have
straight lines and circles that's
distance things but there's a more
deeper underlying geometrical structure
called topology and the idea behind
topology is that certain features of
figures
uh remain the same even when you stretch
the space as long as you don't tear it
so you saw when you stretched the space
there the straight line became curved
and the circle was no longer a circle so
those are not topological features but
still the dot remained inside this
closed figure so that is a topological
feature right so
if you think of time as part of the
geometry of space time you have to ask
well how do we understand geometry we do
it through math we do it through a
particular mathematical theory
that we use it's it's it's our lens by
which we look at this now what i think
is that we've been using the wrong one
okay we've been using the wrong
mathematical tool so what we want is a
feature that remains unchanged even when
you stretch now what normal topology
does you take a circle and you take its
circumference off so it has that fuzzy
edge and you notice as you stretch it it
still is a fuzzy edge there's still no
boundary to the circle so the
boundarylessness is a property that's
invariant under this stretching and
standard topology uses that as the basic
organizational structure
and that's called an open set a set that
doesn't have a boundary or it doesn't
have an edge has an open set and then
standard topology lays down some axioms
about the open sets i'm just going to
list them here the whole space is an
open set the empty set is an open set if
you have a bunch of different open sets
and you union them together you join
them all together sort of merge them
that's an open set and if you have two
overlapping open sets their
intersection is an open set
that's the standard mathematics says
that's what open sets are like you
specify the topology of a space by
specifying the open sets and then you
analyze it now i think that was the
wrong place to start okay it was the
wrong structure to grab
so we need another structure that's
invariant under this stretching well
here's one think of continuous lines you
remember in euclidean geometry used a
pencil it draws continuous lines they
remain continuous lines under stretching
so i'm going to take those things lines
and i'm going to throw away the closed
line i'm going to throw away the circle
so just take the open lines the ones
that don't come back on themselves i'm
going to say that's the basics of the
geometry the most fundamental deep
geometrical structure is given by the
continuous lines
what am i going to do with that well i'm
going to have some axioms to tell you
what lines have to be like simple axioms
every line has at least two points that
one's kind of really easy this is really
not very complicated the next nice thing
about lines is that they're made up of
shorter lines if you have a line like
that you can cut it into pieces like a b
and c all of those are lines continuous
lines but a together with c those
disconnected pieces don't make a line so
that's an axiom about what lines are
like that these things have to satisfy
and then there's another axiom about how
you can make longer lines out of shorter
ones so if i have a line from a to b and
another line from b to c i can join them
together if they overlap the right way i
can join them together to make a longer
line so i've got just as in the standard
theory i have there are four axioms here
i've got these three axioms about the
ways lines behave
at this very deep fundamental
geometrical level now the interesting
thing about lines is you can put
directions on them all right so we
talked about the direction of time
if you say put a direction on an open
set i wouldn't know what to do there's
no mathematical operation that
corresponds to putting a direction on an
open set but if you give me a line i
know what you mean put a direction on it
okay so i can talk about directed lines
so the idea of directionality is going
to be very deeply built into the
mathematics here
so let's try and think about space-time
in terms of this how about euclidean
space three-dimensional euclidean space
all kinds of nice continuous lines that
run around in all different directions
those would give me the very deepest
most fundamental structure of euclidean
space and i've put arrows on both ends
because a line in space if it goes from
a to b it also goes back from b to a
doesn't have a directionality to it
but let's try and do this with space
time
now here's the
old classical space-time the one that
craig talked about with these slices
these simultaneity slices that run that
chop it up this way and there's the sun
and the earth orbiting around the sun
and
what i would like to do what you can do
is describe this geometry in terms of
these lines it's kind of a complicated
thing to do because you've got to
describe these
horizontal slices and then you have to
describe these other things
the beautiful thing
is that if we give up classical physics
the one that we thought that's where
that's what time we always thought of
time and classical physics if we give up
classical physics and we go to
relativity
the fundamental structure in space time
doesn't look like this it's much simpler
the fundamental structure of space-time
and relativity is a light cone structure
that's why light is so special in
relativity because every point in space
time
there's where light would go if you
emitted it from that point or how light
could get there and that forms a
fundamental geometrical structure that's
the relativistic structure relativity is
sort of most of it built into just this
spacetime
so now you have a nice suggestion you
can't do this in classical physics you
need relativistic physics
suppose i now have a relativistic space
time there's the earth orbiting the sun
always staying within the light cone
because the earth can't go faster than
light so it's its trajectory its line
always sits inside the light cone
take as real take as
fundamental in the geometry of
space-time only those lines the lines
that a particle could travel or the
lines that a that a light ray could
travel on and get rid of all the rest of
it throw the rest of it away
all that's left now what's special about
those lines every all of those events
are ordered in time have a definite time
order and because we can put arrows in
at a basic level on this we say well
furthermore time
goes a certain way okay
in the mathematics if you switch the
mathematics i think the reason it's hard
for physicists to see the direction of
time
is they
used a piece of mathematics that was
developed to analyze space and there is
no direction in space
so you have this mathematical theory
built for something with no direction in
it you then try to analyze space time
and you say gosh i don't see a direction
anymore it must be an illusion
it's not an illusion we're getting older
right it's not an illusion that that
actually i can i can make a decision now
about what to eat for dinner and not
what to have had for breakfast right
those aren't illusions and the reason
physicists sometimes think they're
illusions they're using a mathematics
where they're not easy to see you switch
the mathematics everything's going to
work out very cleanly and you'll stop
hearing all the strange stuff about how
it's just an illusion
because he's conflated the flare of time
with the time asymmetry and i've worked
so hard through my career to separate
these two of course there's an asymmetry
of time there's an ac asymmetry of the
world states of the world in time nobody
here would disagree with that there
there are later states and earlier
states older people you get older
younger all the rest of it of course
that's true that's a property of the
world in time property of states of the
world in time it's not a property at
time itself you can draw a diagram put
an arrow on it if you like but unless
you can actually physically measure such
a thing
it's it's meaningless what we actually
measure in the world are sequences of
states like the falling glass and so on
that's time asymmetry that's not the
flow of time that's not this
psychological impression we have from
the laying down of memories and all the
other stuff up here the time is moving
time isn't moving that's an illusion
asymmetry of time is not an illusion
it's real and it's a property of states
of the world and it originates in how
the universe began the initial state of
the universe
i agree
so he can answer them both at the same
time no pun intended so i i agree with
paul's sentiment here and i want to add
because i'm all about measurements and
experiments now you have this very
intriguing mathematical theory
we also have this very successful
mathematical theory of einstein general
relativity which has passed all these
tests explains the gps stuff all the
weird stuff we observed near black holes
and in our early universe so
there are two logical possibilities
either your theory predicts exactly the
same thing as einstein's for all the
measurements or predicts something
different
that we can test so which of the two is
this is you're thinking the wrong level
what i'm i what i did not produce was a
physical theory what i produced
mathematics is the language in which you
write physical theories
okay it is it is the language in which
you articulate a physical theory but
there are now you can re-articulate
einstein's equations in this language is
that possible to do that sure so then
you're just saying
do you come out has somebody done it
i've and i think so he's asking he's
asking did you come out with the same
result of course you're gonna have it's
you're writing the same theory in two
different languages if if i translate a
novel from english into french it better
not have a different ending
right
it better not have different predictions
when i translate it from one language to
another it's just a mistake to think
that what i'm doing is something that
that would give to a different
prediction i'm trying to to state the
physics in a language in which its
implications are clear i think he
answered yes to your question i think he
answers no i think he has no
consequences he's i think you're saying
and correct me if i'm wrong there are
only two logical options yes or no right
either you predict that all experimental
tests will agree with general relativity
yes
if you rewrite general relativity in
these terms you'll get all the
predictions
equivalent mathematical theory you're
just putting different words to the
exact mathematics same mathematical
equations
that's actually important it's really
it's really a different mathematical
tool it actually has different makes
different uh judgments about things i
it's not experimentally but but it's
there's not enough time the fact of the
matter i mean so once you've constructed
the space time do you think there was a
fact of the matter about how you got
there what do you mean how i got how you
constructed the space time i'm i'm just
exaggerating i wouldn't matter how you
got to the answer is that what you're
asking yeah so if you end up with a
strength come up with the same
space-time model
and now you've given a story about how
you get that space-time model
i'm going to end up with something where
there
is now
we keep having this this question about
which way the arrows are pointing
the other way the arrow means there's a
there's an obvious completely
conventional issue about what an arrow
means right when i put it one way and i
put an arrow this way it's a convention
that the arrow points in the direction
you can go rather than the direction you
can't go right we could do it off the
other room but the point is what the
arrow represents is
and they're often conflated in exactly
this model
one is when you use an arrow like uh on
a compass you know a compass needle it's
pointing north it doesn't mean you're
moving north
the other is the arrow that you release
from the bow it's moving okay so arrows
a metaphor for two completely distinct
distinct things one is an asymmetry the
compass is the asymmetry in the north
pole and south pole and the other is
motion
and nobody denies the arrow of the
asymmetry the arrow of time i've been
talking about the asymmetry of the world
in time that's one arrow the arrow of
motion or movement the flare of time the
passage of time all that stuff that's
the thing that is the illusion that's
that's the standard physics position
well he's saying he's using the wrong
tools he doesn't yeah right so using the
wrong tools to make a point
so if tim's uh reformulation of this has
no observable consequences i'd rather
stick with what i know and understand
because i think it's just conflating a
lot of issues like the two metaphors of
the arrow get conflated it just does a
disservice to the subject
i love that it's heating up here
thank you for raising the temperature
tim that said i think it's worse than
that i think
that
i think that what
what you just said isn't just an
equivalent way of saying things i think
you're actually just logically
self-destructed because
you said that you said that you your
theory makes exactly all the same
predictions as einstein's generativity
but you also said that it's supposed to
explain why i look older now than i did
on my 10th birthday and and that's an
observational fact that's an experiment
let me just finish the sentence so if
it's an experimental fact that i look
older now than on my 10th birthday
and yet your theory makes exactly the
same prediction for all experimental
facts as einstein's theory
then i you have to concede einstein his
theory also explains why i look older
now
the reason you think
no no the reason you think i've counted
you is you're not listening to anything
i say
i said i don't have a uni a different
theory i have a different mathematics in
which to write the same theory right
it's not a different theory i just don't
think there's any illusion everybody up
here saying there's some illusion
i think there is no illusion but just
there's a thing that you said that you
can explain through you said that's
wrong right yeah and you said you can
explain why i look older now and that i
cannot explain why i look older now
right i didn't say that didn't you you
said this is
i said it's a fact that i'm getting oh
it's not an illusion i'm getting older
all the time
and it's not an illusion i can make a
decision about what you have for dinner
correlate with older states of your body
of course but that has nothing states of
the world
that has nothing to do with it
correlate with being in different parts
of the world that has nothing to do with
time well we're talking about later
states in earlier stages
distinction between earlier and later
if i've got two models so i could
generate one space-time model with the
earlier than relation i could generate
one with the later then relation sure
are they the same
or are they
or is there some difference
the original glass we had fallen
let's think about what we thought about
that
here's something that happens all the
times glasses fall and they shatter
here's something that never happens
pieces of glass recombine and jump up
the only difference between those is the
direction of time the direction of time
is not an illusion it's not something
the way you generate the space time
explains the direction
again
this is not a contrary theory to
relativity i'm not
maybe if i repeat something enough times
it'll get through
can you can you perform an experiment to
show that time is an illusion
well i would turn it around the other
way well can you i mean we you prove
things if you you have a if you have a
theory that time is an illusion what
experiment what data can we collect
the very notion the time is flowing is
an inco philosophically incoherent one
that has no basis in physics and
somebody who claims the time is moving
and better show me the meter that
measures but you but you're you're
claiming that time is an illusion show
me the meter that measures that uh
well can we measure illusions well you
but you just stated
can we measure let me let me put it this
way can we measure
the illusion
of the rotating
valley dancer thinking that the world is
rotating can we measure that illusion i
suppose if you if you've got wire brain
up and so on you could so i suppose that
you can wire your brain up and show the
laying down of memories and so on and
you could even do experiments like what
was einstein said that the hour in the
dentist chair and an hour with a pretty
girl you know seemed very different you
could probably measure that but you need
to talk to a neuroscientist not a
physicist
because it's all about neuroscience
on someone else no no no no i'm saying
that there's nothing about time this is
a property of psychology and and i guess
these guys use meters yeah i don't i
don't know but i'm sure you could
somehow you can measure what we're
talking about uh probably rather
precisely but you haven't figured out
the experiment that would be i've just
told you the basis of it yeah yeah you
put something overhead with wires into
your neurons so you bring a pretty girl
into the room and then you have a
conversation the only way the measure
time is our perception of time that's
what you're saying because the flow of
time is our perception yes it's just the
perception we have because time is the
is an illusion right because it's not
the flow of time there's nothing in time
itself that flows or moves
okay it's our impression of states of
the world as they succeed each other we
have this illusion of movement just like
the rotation we have an illusion of
rotation okay it's all in here
can you disprove the time is an illusion
disprove that time is an illusion well
it's science says if you prove something
you have to be able to disprove okay so
supposing we discovered that there was a
second dimension of time and we could
say that this this dimension of time is
moving relative to that dimension of
time just like an object can move
through space
in time okay that's what we mean by
movement if we had a second time
dimension then we could talk about it in
fact i read a book when i was a teenager
by a south african guy what was his name
uh no no no no um
but long before that about exactly this
that there are a whole sequence the
infinite number of time dimensions and
each one is moving relative to the other
one because the notion of time moving
relative to itself is meaningless
so uh what was the name of this guy
john dunn
we're hitting the source of a lot of
this confusion okay so over and we've
heard several times there's a certain
claim that's meaningless
time passes one second per second that's
meaningless what could that tell you
wait
here's because well what else could it
be here's something that's not
meaningless think of the notion of a
fair rate of exchange between currencies
yes so there's a fair rate of exchange
between dollars and euros that's a good
number whatever it is it's dollars and
yen that's a good number dollars and
dollars
man there's a fair rate of exchange
between dollars and dollars and it's one
for one i don't have to check if you
think it's something else i'll you know
i'll try to say no right so
so there's this idea it's a bad it's a
bad art just a bad argument that because
there's only one as it were rate that
time passes that's meaningless it
doesn't mean anything it's perfectly
meaningful to say you can only exchange
money fairly dollars for dollars one for
one even though you don't have to check
i don't have to go into a laboratory and
measure that in that same sense space
flows no yeah one meter it doesn't
there's no directionality to space
there's a directionality of time
an arrowhead i try to inject a little
bit of experimental viewpoint into this
because i think we've
gone dangerously close to now telling
our universe a bit about how we wanted
to be to conform with our notions about
what we feel comfortable about and
ultimately i feel our job as scientists
shouldn't be to tell our universe how to
behave but to look at her very carefully
and see
how does it work and i what i think
we've learned so far is
by looking very carefully is
that we we have a pretty good idea of
what happened during the last 13.8
billion years
we have a much shadier idea but a lot of
ideas what happened before that and
what's going to happen in the in the
distant future
but there's also a frontier of our
ignorance behind which beyond which
we're really quite clueless and we
should be honest for truth in
advertising error dirty laundry here and
say that
we are very confident talking about time
only in domains where we have a lot of
clocks either man-made clocks or
nature-made clocks like atoms
yet
very early on and in the very very
distant future there might be situations
where there are no clocks and i'm not
just talking about digital watches now
but i'm talking about atoms
if all of this stuff has somehow been
destroyed if we just have some kind of
soup
where nothing is changing at all where
nothing is happening
then
we can't do any of einstein's games to
define
space-time through clocks and cleverness
does it even make sense to talk about
time flowing can
there be time
in any meaningful sense without change
if nothing is happening does it make
sense to talk about time flowing we it
i'm not claiming i know the answer i
just want to throw this question out
here because it may very well be that
rather than getting stuck into the
question about whether there's a north
of the north pole which is classical
general relativity when we embrace
quantum mechanics and
successfully manage to marry it with
relativity which we haven't managed to
yet we might actually end up with a
situation where we have some kind of
fuzzy
situation where that's right where time
as
the time we thought we knew so well it
could be an emergent property yeah
there's an emergent property and
assuming time here is it's a basic
concept yes so it's still emerging it
could be yeah
it's still in its birth i think you see
it turns out as mac says when you apply
quantum mechanics to the universe it
gets much more subtle and it could well
be that the uh world that we perceive
which has what we were
in the trade called a quasi-classical
space-time
that we see all around us might be
something which is very special state of
the universe so it emerged from the
ferment of a quantum big bang and it
congealed into this sort of
quasi-space-time quasi-classical space
style but it may not be fundamental
because you have to all discuss
einstein's theories relativity and this
is related to space-time and quantum
mechanics which you bring up cannot yet
be even united with this theory that's
right
so we have to go all over again and have
this discussion some other time when
this has happened well which i think
means that also studying the question of
time and what it really is isn't
something
which is of interest merely
because it's fascinating philosophically
speaking but it's also related to all of
the most difficult unsolved problems in
physics
and i think none of us can confidently
say we know what the ultimate theory of
everything in physics is going to be but
i think whatever it is
really understanding the nature of time
is going to be one of the key
ingredients of it well that's a good way
to end we've we've run out of time